on passe s'ils voulaient bien une
actualité moins dramatique avec ce
mouvement des agriculteurs on connaît
leurs motifs de mécontentement d'abord
il ne supporte plus en plus mal d'être
considéré de façon négative par une
grande partie de l'opinion ils se
plaignent aussi de prix trop bas et ils
ont donc décidé aujourd'hui avec leurs
tracteurs en tout cas certain nombre
d'entre eux de bloquer paris opération
qui n'est pas autorisé mais comme
l'expliquent six mois me qui est le
président des jeunes agriculteurs des
hauts de france de toute façon quand on
manifeste normalement on nous écoute pas
début octobre une deuxième en octobre
ça a pas réagi suffisamment il a fallu
aller la hausse a dit qu'il fallait pas
c'est à dire ici je vais chanter en
espérant que ça fasse réagir si ça fait
pas réagir assez rapidement
est ce que le reste voilà et ce
mouvement suscite une adhésion en tout
cas une approbation sans nuance du
gouvernement en la personne de didier
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture
qui était ce matin sur europe 1 mais je
soutiens leur colère et leur
manifestation je comprends leur
ras-le-bol et j'essaie d'apporter des
réponses
je soutiens à leur colère et l'éveil
cette manifestation parce que
aujourd'hui trop c'est trop
il y en a assez de ce dénigrement
permanent de ce malentendu entre la
société civile entre la société entre
les métropoles et la ruralité entre les
agriculteurs et les concitoyens pas de
lévis vous les comprenez ces
agriculteurs toute façon ils disent
quand on manifeste de façon organisée et
est licite
il se passe rien c'est vrai que quand on
regarde les images aujourd'hui sur le
périphérique c'est impressionnant mais
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu ou sur les
champs-elysées mais par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu l'année dernière avec les
gilet jaune c'est des lords anglais
c'est ces agriculteurs ils ont une
qualité ils ont été tout à fait
exemplaire même si voilà il n'y avait
pas l'autorisation d'investir les champs
elysées sont allés en face du fouquet's
mais franchement on rêverait d'avoir les
manifestations comme ça hein
si si digne et ordonné parce qu'en plus
ils ont un service d'ordre donc ils
savent s'organiser contrairement voilà
aux scènes qu'on a dû l'année dernière
avec les gilets jaunes
ceci dit je pense que le gouvernement
entend ici une main une chose que je
comprends moins c'est cet acharnement
contre les accords de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et d'autres
pays qui sont contestés aussi par les
agriculteurs
quand notamment l'amérique du sud avec
le mercosur l'érotisme et mentalement et
je pense vu de l'étranger c'est
peut-être les choses plus intéressantes
à dire ici pour moi pour vous c'est le
fait que en france le débat est toujours
installé d'une seule façon c'est à dire
on a toujours l'impression que c'est les
produits de ces pays là qui vont envahir
la france ils vont concurrencer les
produits français et s'est jamais
linverse alors que c'est vraiment des
boulevards à double sens qu'on ouvre là
et par exemple les agriculteurs italiens
n'ont jamais rien dit parce qu'il voit
vraiment des avantages en termes
d'exportations dernier de production
extraordinaire à ouvrir leurs marchés à
l'étranger je comprends pas pourquoi ici
en france on a toujours l'impression que
c'est juste les produits des autres qui
vont nous envahir et pâle inverse alors
que la france a des produits
extraordinaires donc il faut qu'elle ait
plus de confiance dans ces produits
il faut être conquérant et aller à la
conquête des marchés
laurent alexandre 72 % des internautes
qui nous suivent et qui se prononce sur
twitter considère que des agriculteurs
ont raison de bloquer paris et vous je
pense que le gouvernement ne respecte
pas les agriculteurs pour donner des
gages aux écologistes
on n'arrête pas d'emmerder les
agriculteurs sur le glyphosate ont à
raconter une quantité de mensonges qui
est hallucinante
le gouvernement ne cesse de mentir sur
le big up before that sur les pesticides
aussi je ne parle même pas de ségolène
royal qui annonçait il n'y a pas très
longtemps que le cancer du sein était
dûe aux pesticides ce qui est totalement
faux ce qui est un mensonge
même s'il est dit par quelqu'un qui est
une assurance absolument incroyable et
qui est ségolène royal sur les ogm sur
l'ensemble des avancées technologiques
on emmerde les agriculteurs et on bloque
la guilde d'offres
l'agriculture française donc la grippe
bashing conduit à ce que les gens qui
nous nourrissent soient considérés comme
des assassins par une partie de la
population
tout ça pour donner des gages à
l'écologie politique donc la crise
d'aujourd'hui
elle est l'aboutissement d'un
dénigrement systématique du monde du
métier d agriculteur mais le
gouvernement est en train de gagner à
jouer au con la france a maintenant une
balance agricole négative avec l'union
européenne et dans deux ans la balance
agricole totale à l'échelle du monde
entier de la france va être négative
pour la première fois de son histoire la
france va importer sa nourriture et tout
ça à cause de la folie environnementale
qui pousse le gouvernement à sa guise et
les agriculteurs et qui les empêche de
créer l'agriculture moderne que les
autres pays sont en train de grès créés
grâce aux nouvelles technologies
il faut arrêter de dire des conneries
sur le glyphosate sur les ogm sur les
pesticides
ce n'est plus possible sinon la france
ne va plus nourrir et on n'avait pas
beaucoup de filières excédentaire s'il
est rare filière où notre commerce
extérieur sont excédentaires s'effondre
que va devenir les que vont devenir les
prochaines générations
on va avoir un vrai effondrement une
vraie décroissance est pas une
décroissance souhaitez mais des
croissances imposées à cause de la
disparition de tous nos points forts
industriel économique et agricole
donc il faut faire aujourd'hui très
attention nous ne pouvons pas perdre une
filière technologique de plus ce qui
caractérise la france depuis 30 ans et
que nous perdons nos leaderships secteur
après secteur
nous n'avons plus d'industrie du télécom
par exemple il ne faut pas faire la même
bêtise avec l'agroalimentaire qui doit
rester un point fort donc arrêtons
d'emmerder les agriculteurs arrêtons de
donner des gages aux écologistes
radicaux
ce qui conduit à transformer les
agriculteurs en bouc émissaire et à
détruire l'agriculture française on
attend vous êtes sensible à ces
arguments
je vais essayer de prendre le
contrepoint celle ci s'est dit avec
tellement d'assurance qu'on a va être
obligé de taxer dire des bêtises moi je
connais bien la bretagne d'accord si
vous avez en bretagne par exemple il ya
une branche qui s'appelle le tourisme
est la plus grande pourvoyeuse d'emplois
de toute la région
cette branche et les menaces et peuvent
par ce qu'on appelle les algues vertes
algues vertes viennent de l'agriculture
intensive fait à partir de là de
l'élevage de porcs ça qui est la grande
halle à la grande industrie agricoles
d'exportation de la bretagne
donc le problème c'est le suivant c est
ce qu on se baigne dans la baie de saint
brieuc ou dans la baie de morlaix ou ou
même dans le golfe du morbihan et on
accueille des touristes et on a une
balance du tourisme qui est largement
excédentaire ou on continue à construire
ddd ferme à cochons de plus en plus
grande
là où je suis pas d'accord avec vous
notamment c'est sur l'historique la
décroissance de la balance extérieure
agricole elle n'a pas de cette année où
on n'a pas encore interdit glyphosate
s'y sentait qu'on y arrive dans deux ans
ce que moi je ne pense pas
personnellement
l'élevage porcin ça fait 20 ans que même
si ça fait au moins vingt ans que les
associations qui sont qui sont les seuls
sur scène les premiers à avoir tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé en bretagne s'est
passé c'est pas les radicaux écologistes
c'est l'association des pêcheurs à la
ligne des salmonidés en bretagne c'est
eux qui ont mené le combat et qui ont
expliqué que s'il y avait plus de
poissons dans les rivières en bretagne
c'est parce qu'il y avait des rejets de
qui venait de l'épandage et les avoirs
des événements ils ont fait de nombre de
nos wii mais beaucoup pas assez vite
hélas pas assez vite oui il ya quelques
efforts qui sont faits il ya une pendant
très très longtemps
il ya eu un formidable connivence des
pouvoirs publics avec ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la pollution agricole c'est vrai
en bretagne c'est vrai ailleurs les
ministres d'agriculture l actuel nous a
donné encore un exemple chez les paysans
manifestent contre les directives et
dieu sait qu'on a entendu parler
l'interdiction de manifester sur les
champs elysées le préfet l'allemand et
doit s'il doit se cacher là aujourd'hui
le nouveau préfet qui devait absolument
faire respecter la loi dans paris et
magna un ministre qui dit ah ben moi
mais mes gars à moi avec leurs tracteurs
ils ont réussi à ridiculiser la police
et moi je les soutiens ça c'est du
gouvernement ça c'est de la répression
ça c'est du maintien de l'ordre ça c'est
républicain
voilà donc tout ça fait un drôle de
de jaillir un drôle de lisier dans
laquelle nous pataugeons et dans
laquelle il pas toujours beau à voir oui
il ya une grille bashing il faut laisser
il faut respecter les paysans bien sûr
où il faut les aider notamment il faut
bloquer il faut quand même s'interroger
pourquoi est ce que dans un monde de
plus en plus ouverts l'agriculture au
fur et à mesure que le sait les marchés
se sont ouverts a réduit ses excédents
agricoles
comment ça se fait que au fur et à
mesure on a ouvert les frontières par
différentes accords internationaux
les accords omc les accords avec le
canada les accords à venir avec le
mercosur
au fur et à mesure la balance
commerciale française s'effondre
pourquoi alors qu'on a pas de règle
c'est faux de dire qu'on a des
réglementations nettement plus difficile
qu'en italie ou en espagne convoqué
c'est assez rare
oui on signera en soi un petit peu oui
je suis d'accord c'est vrai que certains
joueurs aient songé à faire ça fait pas
défense le problème c'est que il ya des
gens qui disent que la terre bientôt à
force de l'agavé avec des produits
chimiques
la terre ne produira plus rien parce
qu'il ya plus vers de terre on en
utilise un sur six est de moins en moins
et la balance est l'un des trois pays au
monde où il ya le plus de vers de terre
va là où c'est à moi maintenant
s'effondrer dale boylan ils ont dit non
à la guerre des pays où il ya plus de
gars de terre donc c'est un argument qui
ne tient pas de moustiques sur les parts
abri ouais ouais de celui celle exercée
paco c'est exactement départ brizola
permet plus haut en émotion que collet
avance qu'il ya un traitement et
l'aérodynamique
il s'est amélioré pour diminuer le
nombre de co2 émis au 100 km que fait
que les pare brise ne sont plus à par
rapport au pare-brise nathan car leur
ardoise aussi aux gitans va pas faire là
on va pas faire la liste de tout ce que
les collègues se logguer raconte comme
qu'elle utilise ont alors cherché à être
avez vous envie de prendre position dans
ce débat au oui je suis pas du tout
spécialiste dit economista sacré pour la
troisième année consécutive le modèle
agricole français comme le modèle le
plus durable
de plus le plus vertueux en terme de
palper du vin le plus vertueux en terme
de préservation de l'environnement et
d'économie durable
donc ça veut dire qu'effectivement les
aviculteurs français font énormément
d'efforts dans leurs revendications il
ya évidemment une dimension économique
il ya 30 % des agriculteurs qui gagnent
moins de 350 euros par mois et 20 % qui
ne se paye pas du tout aucun record de
buts ils ne supporteraient salaces et
sauf que c'est un chiffre que personne
ne vérifie c'est un chiffre que personne
je sais c'est un chiffre qui est qu'il
vient dans le débat
ce chiffre là on a un peu du mal appuyée
par ce que et notamment on n'arrive pas
à faire la différence entre les par
exemple des agriculteurs beaucoup
frapperait très forte proportion en deux
emplois en deux ans deux occupations
c'était on a beaucoup de mal à vérifier
ce chiffre
y compris la aimé ça rigole n'arrive
shalit et sociale agricole c'est moi de
nature on part donc j'ai dit non j'ai
appris et donc vous pensez de leurs
conditions de vie sont non son parfum
qui se plaignent pour pas grand chose
non j'ai pas dit ce mail je pense que on
a tort de ne pas aider les agriculteurs
à faire la transition écologique
une des choses que j'aimerais tirer si
c'est que on parle beaucoup de
transition écologique mais on est en
train de mesures est en fait par ces
manifestations là mais d'autres à quel
point la transition écologique va
obliger des professions entière mais
aussi moins de toute la population à
changer de mode de vie
deux modes de travail c'est vrai sur les
modes de transport on sait c'est vrai
sur les c'est vrai sur les sur les modes
agricole l'agriculture c'est 20 pour ses
plus de 20% des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre c'est un enjeu majeur
ou alors on décide et dont un au fond
oui donnez la priorité ceux du giec donc
mondialement et demi puisque c'est là il
ya une question qui fait plaisir je
reçois alors jetez y compris les
pendules à l'heure la tendance est en
train de vous régaler devenu non non
c'est faux c'est faux le port permet le
porte-parole le parcours non non non
non le porte parole du géant qu'en
france on connaît ce jeu vous est donc
allé interviewer monsieur et demande lui
ces chiffres sont fous ça ce serait
intéressant parce que lui c'est un vrai
scientifique c'est pas greta merdassi
alors le débat fait rage aussi chez nos
internautes
nicole soutient totalement les
agriculteurs même s'ils bloquent paris
tandis que si je considère que ces
derniers ont pollué les sols balancer
des produits à gogo pendant des années
un petit tacle au passage de nicole mai
0,6 et par là même qui nous dit didier
guillaume est un pantin
là il soutient les agriculteurs et
d'autres fois il prend des décisions
contre eux et puis cette réflexion de
mar bat qui nous dit tous ces blocages
ne savent pas à grand chose puisque
c'est bruxelles qui décide et enfin
cette phrase pleine de sagesse la
transition vers l'agriculture raisonnée
est indispensable mais prendra du temps